[Applause]
are incredible you are sending us to all
kinds of places in our solar system it
is beyond impressive and exciting and
speaking of exciting this is the big day
where we find out the name of NASA's
next Mars rover this journey started
back in August we had 28,000 entries
4,700 judges and it's all brought us
right here to learn that winning name I
am in Burke Virginia at Lake Braddock
secondary school
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so my name is the end I'm the future
engineers one of the partner
organizations that put on this contest
and I bet we have some future engineers
in this room and some future scientists
and some future explorers and guess what
we are the Artemis generation we are
sending humans back to the moon we are
exploring bars and I cannot wait to find
out the name for the next robotic
Explorer headed to Mars so without
further ado I'm gonna bring out two very
important people we have two of NASA's
top leading scientists we have dr. Tom
mr. Buchan also known as dr. Z he's in
charge of all of science at NASA and he
has a personal preference for the Sun
and also the planet Mercury he's also
accompanied by dr. Laurie glaze back
here she's in charge of all of planetary
science at NASA and she loves volcanoes
but not the ones here are the ones in
our solar system so without further ado
I'm gonna let dr. Z take it away thank
you so much
hey Thank You Diann and hi everybody
here at the high school at JPL and
everywhere around the world we're making
history right now we're making history
right here today we are naming a
spacecraft that will go to Mars and make
measurements we've never made before it
will be the first leg of the first round
trip of humanity to Mars bringing back
these samples that our secrets about
life itself and the name of this mission
is
[Music]
[Applause]
you know curiosity got to planet Mars
when many of you were babies or little
kids and curiosity is what we need when
we explore it pulls it forward it's
about that motivation to explore beyond
what's there
curiosity is always part of exploration
but when you flip over that metal you
look at the other side what is there
it's perseverance there has never been
exploration never never be making
history without perseverance
perseverance and curiosity together are
what exploration is all about
perseverance is a strong world a word
it's about making progress despite
obstacles everybody who's ever tried
building hardware I tried knows how
important it is and it will be important
for this role today but as we go forward
spec's space exploration is hard and
it's difficult it has been difficult in
the past but it's so exciting and we
need everybody to engage we need the
Artemis generation in this room all of
you and many more in the United States
and beyond we go together to Mars
together with the United States and with
our international and commercial
communities and the perseverance Rohwer
will lead the way to the next generation
of exploration exploration that at this
moment in time we haven't even thought
of but we need you to help it could be
any of you to be part of this and I'm so
excited be here today with all of you
Lori take it away
all right Thank You Thomas and now what
we've been waiting for it is now my
great honor to invite the winner of the
Mars rover naming contest to come to the
stage
please join me in a big round of
applause for your classmate who
submitted perseverance as the winning
name come on Alex Mathur
[Applause]
all right
who wants to hear that say all right so
your mics up right yeah all right Alex
do you want to read us your essay I do
if I can unfold this paper Gerry off
singing in sight spirit opportunity if
you think about it all of these names of
past Mars rovers are qualities we
possess as humans we are always curious
and seek opportunity we have the spirit
and insight to explore the moon Mars and
beyond
but if Rovers are to be the qualities of
us as a race we missed the most
important thing perseverance we as
humans evolved as creatures who could
learn to adapt to any situation no
matter how harsh we are a species of
explorers and we will meet many setbacks
on the way to Mars however we can
persevere we not as a nation but as
humans will not give up the human race
will always persevere into the future
[Applause]
we're gonna have a moment now I have a
little Q&A with Alex so congratulations
again Alex thank you this is a really
tremendous achievement I enjoyed meeting
you I got to be one of the four
panelists that did the interviews with
the nine finalists and so it's great to
finally get to meet you in person
and when we had our interview we talked
about a lot of different things but
maybe you could share with the group
here today the folks in the room and the
folks that are watching us online why it
is that you love space so much that's
actually really easy when I turned 11 my
parents decided to send me to Space Camp
as a birthday present and originally I
gotta know what to expect but I don't
know fam if you have ever been to Space
Camp but as you're driving up to the
campus there's this building that is
blocking the view of the model of the
Saturn 5 that's just on campus and as
you drive up to the campus you see the
capsule of the Saturn 5 slowly rise
above the building and 11-year old me
saw that and lost his mind I immediately
knew that space is something I was doing
for the rest of my life that is just a
great story I love it it's inspirational
and a lot of us at NASA were in your
shoes when we were your age and we're
inspired to go on and become engineers
and scientists and explorers and it took
for all of us an enormous amount of
perseverance to get to where we are
today so we really appreciate the name
that you've suggested for our next Mars
rover so just one more question can you
share with us what your goals are as a
young person who wants to make your own
mark in exploration so let's start a
little bit more short-term goals high
school diploma
get that first get those two years of
language do those and after that I want
Goga college get a degree in some form
of engineering or science space
engineering and Astronautics sound good
right now and then after that go work at
NASA as an engineer perfect sounds like
a great plan I do so could you tell me
more about the Artemis program so we're
really excited about Artemis you know
we've been in low Earth orbit with the
International Space Station the whole
duration of your life's if your students
here for over 18 years there's always
been Americans up there together with
their international partners and it's
time to go beyond we want to go to the
moon with that next generation of
explorers and the new technologists go
to the moon learn how to stay there
sustainably not to stay there forever
but to learn how to go to Mars because
even though we're sending a roller this
year to Mars we really want to send
people and bring them back safely so
that is the ultimate goal of the Artemis
generation all right and in 10 years
most of the people in this room will be
out of college and looking for a job
what are going to be the cool NASA
missions I love that question so let me
tell you about some of the cool things
we'll be doing in about 10 years when
y'all get out of college number one we
talked about the Mars 2020 the
perseverance rover is going to be
collecting samples it's the first leg of
the first round trip from Earth to Mars
and back to bring those samples back to
earth and so we are hoping in the 2030s
that we will be bringing those samples
back here to earth that'll be incredibly
cool we also have a mission right now
that we're beginning work on called
dragon fly which is going to be a
mission to send an octocopter drone to
the surface of Titan which is a moon of
Saturn really cool place and that one's
supposed to launch in 26 and it's
supposed to land on Titan in 2034 and so
it's going to do some incredible science
on the surface of Titan going even
further than that we're thinking about
missions that could potentially go to
Uranus or Neptune there's a really
important opportunity at the end of the
2020s where all of the planets line up
just right that we could actually go
visit Uranus and Neptune at the same
time so that's a really cool thing that
we're looking at we're thinking about
missions to go land on the surface of
other icy moons like the moon of Europa
that's around Jupiter that's got ice and
we think a liquid ocean beneath we'd
like to land on the surface there or on
cell adesso nother moon of Saturn where
we think there might be liquid oceans
and maybe even potentially signs of life
inside those liquid oceans so there are
some incredibly amazing opportunities
that are coming in the 2030s so we look
for all of you guys to join us at NASA
at that time needs you and that's it
needs all of you and that's meets all of
you it's it's very it's quite exciting
we are all exploring this universe it's
amazing all right so next we have a very
special guest someone from your school
district so you know Lake Braddock I'd
love for you all to give a warm welcome
to a superintendent dr. Scott Bray brand
thank you thank you
this is a great day for Alex let's give
Alex a round of applause this is a great
day for Lake Braddock secondary school
give all of yourselves a round of
applause this is a great day two for
Fairfax County Public Schools it's a
great day for NASA it's a great day for
the United States of America we have
always been leaders in space and the
next generation the Artemus generation
is right here happening at late Radek
secondary you are the next generation
for space how about that I want to just
acknowledge a few special guests that
are with us today what you all have done
Alex it's you but it's also this school
and all of your peers creating an
atmosphere to celebrate steam science
technology engineering arts mathematics
that makes the imagination to come up
with the name for the next Mars rover
possible I have three school board
members with me Megan mcLaughlin please
stand Laura Jane Cohen and Rachna
Sizemore Heiser we also have our Regent
assistant superintendent mr. J Pearson
our assistant superintendent for
information technology Mary Beth Liu
class and also I know he's here your
principal dr. Daniel Smith dr. Smith
I also know I want every one of you
because I learned that science olympiad
this this is not an accident that it's
here at Lake Braddock Science Olympiad
at the middle school was 1st and 3rd at
the regional competition team fusion and
team fission please stand if you were on
either of those two teams team fusion
recognize stay standing stay standing
[Music]
[Applause]
where's your sponsor by the way the
spots of what's your what wave and be
recognized give her a big round of
applause just like Alex said about going
to Space Camp plants the see your
teachers here at Lake Braddock this
school is planning the seed in you right
planting the seed in you to do whatever
you want to dream whatever you want to
be whomever you want and I hope now as
you go out and I think Mars is one of
those you can see in the evening sky
it's one of the planets I think it's
Mars and Venus that's about as good as I
can remember from high school days that
now when you look out in the sky you'll
not just think of Mars you will think of
Lake Braddock secondary school and
forever
now this school will have a role will
have a lasting presence on another
planet in our solar system so it is a
great day for Lake Braddock secondary
school thank you again NASA for all
you've done in Alex congratulations
again on a job well done we're proud of
you
[Applause]
all right we have tons of VIPs here
today I'm also told we have a
representative from Senator Mark Warner
office boma chai are you here can you
stand up Virginia Senator Mark Warner
has provided a pre-recorded message so
we're gonna go and watch that hi there
I'm Virginia Senator Mark Warner and
it's an honor to be able to say a few
words you all today first off I want to
congratulate Alex I'm being chosen to
name the next Rover that we'll get to
explore the surface of Mars as you all
probably know alex was chosen from more
than 28,000 students who submitted
essays and threw their hat in the ring
to get the name this rover upon landing
in Mars perseverance will help NASA
scientists answer key questions about
the conditions on Mars and the potential
for life on that planet pretty cool I
think this is a great achievement that
speaks both to Alex's potential and the
great quality of Virginia's public
school teachers I hope this experience
will inspire everyone to learn more
about NASA's mission and to work hard in
school because there are as our world
changes we're gonna need more young
people who are great at science
technology math and engineering to help
fill the jobs of the future in fact if
you work hard I'm confident that one day
you'll get to not only name the rover
but design it and help ensure it's safe
landing on Mars and beyond once again
congratulations to Alex and everybody in
the school on this awesome lucky
achievement keep reaching for the stars
all right and now we're going to have a
bit of a shout out moment so at the
beginning of this contest NASA did an
all-call for organizations to help run
the name the rover contest to
organizations stepped up and volunteered
their time their effort their expertise
to help them make all of this happen
those organizations are patel education
and future engineers but so does so many
things they've helped from recruiting
judges to engaging teachers they've been
there every step of the way
future engineers is my organization
we're an education technology company
that specializes in student contests and
challenges and we really played a role
in the online portal to manage all of
those 28,000 entries but we also have
some pretty awesome prize that's
associated with this challenge of course
the ultimate prize is naming the next
Mars rover but I'm excited to say that
Alex and his family will also be sent
all the way down to Cape Canaveral
Florida to watch that Rover launch in
July and providing that trip we have
Amazon Web Services here as the prize
provider and I'm excited to have Jamie
Baker from Amazon come on stage Alex
wanted to come over Alex's family why
don't you come on up
[Applause]
congratulations you guys excited
definitely yeah thank you so much Jamie
we appreciate it
have you guys been doing launch before
not
you haven't been to watch I'm from Cape
Canaveral originally and so you're gonna
love it too you're going to love it
so we're gonna have it go ahead and have
you guys come back offstage how you
feeling pretty good
did you get any sleep last night oh he
got fun he found out last night by the
way so I tried I tried my best but my
brain said no all right there's an
entire assembly right now and a live TV
show because of you and your name feels
good right definitely
you're changing space history and we're
so proud to have you here and you know I
mentioned prizes before there's one more
prize that we want to present here on
stage and it's going to be presented by
a very special guest this guest has had
a role in inspiring students all across
the country teaching them about Mars
about space exploration and about the
rover and its name is Roby
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we go come board somebody should go
ahead and grab the rise the Reverend
given you Thank You Robi so the fun fact
about this prize is this is actually the
semi-finalists prize packet so in this
contest there 155 semi-finalists nine
finalists but there were 28 thousand
entries and those entries were
phenomenal I think you know best of all
that the competition was was fierce oh
yeah it was tough and so we just want to
take a moment to acknowledge every
single student that submitted an entry
in this contest
Your Enthusiasm for space is phenomenal
and we just encourage you to keep going
keep going
that that passion has a home in this
family of space exploration
so come on Robi don't be shy let's go to
the front of the stage everyone hi
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well that's not the effect
[Applause]
it's Wally
[Applause]
good job Brody
all right so one more time I prepare
submission all right now we're going to
go back to YouTube yeah
thanks Dan what does everyone here think
of the new name
right now
and with us here is Jennifer Proctor she
is the mission manager for perseverance
and she's gonna tell us a little bit
more about where the name will go on the
rover thanks Raquel well it is awesome
to be here with the Mars 2020 team for
the unveiling of the name of the rover
how many of you think that is an amazing
name how many of you think Alex is
awesome
all right so now finally now that
everybody knows the name I can open this
package here if we in fact this is the
rover nameplate it's a flight spare it's
not the actual one that's gonna go on
the rover but it's just like it
the rover nameplate is we made several
because even we didn't know what the
rover's name was going to be so this is
the rover nameplate with perseverance on
it
I really like the font selection it's
very Spacey so this is actually it
functions on the rover's robotic arm as
a rock guard my robotic arm people are
sitting here saying so when the rubber
drives you want to make sure that the
cables that are underneath this don't
get damaged and you can see the rover's
robotic arm in this picture and you can
see the nameplate on the arm so now I'm
gonna put this here weighs about a
hundred grams and I think we have some
video of the nameplate being made you
can see there it is it's in a shop that
was local to Los Angeles one of the
things that they did is they covered
this with the thermal black anodized
paint and then they etch in laser the
name perseverance and you'll see that in
the video now I love the name
perseverance for the rover it's awesome
for the rover this Rover is gonna have
challenges those of us who've taken
Rovers to Mars before know that Mars
always throws different things at you
and you figure it out and the rover
persists and persevere and so one of the
things I also really like about this
name though is that perseverance is a
characteristic of the team behind the
rover all of you people in this room all
of the people in the overflow room all
of the people across this country who
spent the last nearly decade getting us
to having a Rover in Florida right now
in 2020 you guys have persevered and now
I need you to help me with with
something so over 3,000 people and
perseverance means overcoming challenges
overcoming obstacles and moving forward
to get to your mission success so over
3,000 people how many problems and
challenges have you guys had to overcome
in the last decade to get us to where we
are today numbers I need numbers like it
I know it's more than a hundred thousand
what I'm
oh yeah I hear a million any other
numbers anybody want to hold okay so
something squared e to the U du DX okay
thank you I knew that JPL would offer me
something like that okay so we have
overcome you have overcome so many
challenges this team has so much
perseverance and we will continue to
have perseverance so in honor of you
guys there's a video here that tells a
little bit about some more folks on the
team when you go to another planet
there's just so much potential for
making brand new discoveries I'm
actually putting something together
that's flying to Mars one way or another
you're going to be on the ground in
seven minutes we want it to be there
safely my name is Heather bottom and I'm
helping prepare the spacecraft that will
fly our next Mars rover to the Martian
surface
my name is Deanna throny Joe and I work
with robotic arms to collect samples on
Mars I'm al Chen and I leave the landing
team for Mars 2020 my name is Michelle
Tommy Pelosi my name is Muji gates
tricker manager tag done my name is
katie stack morgan and i'm helping to
protect the next Mars rover Mars 2020
will be seeking signs of ancient life in
the rock record of Mars what we're
trying to do is to drove around the
surface of this unknown planet collect
samples process the tubes as they come
back to look for things that we call bio
signatures so that eventually we can
bring those samples back to earth and
determine for the very first time did
life exists on Mars but also where could
it be preserved for one more billion
years for us to find it before the rover
actually flies you have to make sure
that everything works properly with the
flight software and the hardware we hit
the atmosphere going you know twelve
thirteen thousand miles per hour after
the journey through space through the
vacuum we try to test all of our
hardware to the environments that we
would see so that's raw a lot of the
testing happens behind
we spend lots and lots of hours here
it's testing everything it gets put in
an oven it gets put in various chambers
and clean rooms so what we can see over
here is the stack spacecraft or the
robotic arm is actually right behind me
this is the place where the magic
happens this is the Mars yard and this
is where our Rovers practice driving
over rocky terrain there are hundreds of
people that have to come together and
build a spacecraft you kind of have to
put those different pieces together and
make sure that those pieces all are
gonna work and I feel like such a lucky
person to be working on this everything
that you're touching and all this hard
work that you're putting in the long
hours 20 years your children will be
leading this in their science book it
feels great
great dog team and now we have a special
surprise we weren't sure we were going
to be able to do this today but because
of the hard work of our team members our
JPL team members in Florida we have a
picture we'd like to share with you not
only has the rover name been selected
but it has been placed on the flight
they're close to Phoenix there's our
close-up image and as you guys all know
when we stow the robotic arm what we
look at with our cameras is perseverance
so we will never forget as we're driving
around Mars now getting the nameplate on
the rover isn't the last thing we have
to do before launch but it's one of the
last things I don't know you guys know a
few more things we have to do here in
the heart races - okay - things all
right right now in the next two weeks
we're finishing out the functional
testing we want to test everything make
sure it works before we send it off to
Mars then we'll start to stow will start
to stow the rover we'll put it inside
the descent stage will encapsulate it
inside of the back shell and the heat
shield add the cruise stage it will be
fully stacked we'll put it on the Atlas
launch vehicle and we'll be ready for a
July 17th
launch all right back to you Raquel
thanks Jennifer and now it is going to
launch perseverance is going to launch
from Cape Canaveral Florida this summer
and it will land on Mars
February 18th of 2021 and now that we
have a name we have launched the rover's
new social media accounts so get your
phones out you can follow at NASA
perservere to see its journey to the Red
Planet and for more information about
the mission you can also visit nasa.gov
slash mars 2020 and mars nasa.gov slash
mars 2020
now before we get back to the school I
know you have it all in you on my count
can we all say go perseverance ready
three two one that was beautiful now
let's hear the students
all right um we might be able to scream
louder than that so I want to say thank
you to JPL thank you to Lake Braddock
secondary school and from all of us
thank you for watching and we're gonna
get ready to yell you guys ready let's
go explore Mars
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's an inspiration seeing other New
Yorkers wanting to take part in an
effort to help their brothers and
sisters who find themselves down and
walk in all the streets
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once the volunteers are assigned an area
they're gonna head out and they're gonna
speak to every person that they engage
and they're gonna ask them if they have
a place to stay tonight and a series of
questions that will allow us to figure
out whether or not they are homeless and
staying on the street and the reason we
talked to everybody is we don't want to
assume that we know about looking at
somebody whether or not they're homeless
[Music]
through this approach over the last
three years we've been able to bring in
more than twenty 450 human beings who've
remained off the streets and that's
really the metric that we're focused on
we have decoys in place to make sure
that we don't miss people in our
estimate and if we do that's taken into
account the most challenging thing about
the work that we do is finding the right
way to engage somebody folks have been
through a system and may have negative
experiences of that system so the idea
is really to make that connection and
make someone feel comfortable to talk
with you so that they're even open to
hearing the ideas on the options that
could be available to them it's this
kind of community support community
effort that's going to help us and
long-term Street homelessness in New
York City
[Music]
[Music]